The thousands of lands have often carried
position between the opposing lines
to create spaces
and facilitate forward passes.
They are the relay between the defensive line
and offensive.
When you position yourself between the lines,
you must be aware
of the space
available and movements of the opposing players.
You play 1 key role in the
build your team's attacks.
You can receive passes from users
and redistribute them to the strikers
or even try to break through
individual to create goal opportunities.
In this situation,
we see the Monegasque defender
come and fix ball to the foot,
we see the middle positioning itself
between the opposing lines to receive the ball.
At that time,
it is the relay between the defensive and offensive line.
It is oriented by three quarters
to be able to play forward
and it poses 1 problem in La Défense
because the
forces 1 defender to come and frame him to limit his
progression at the time of the opponent's framing.
He chooses the combined game,
which will allow the attack in Monegasque
to hit the ball in the feet
to open 1 striking angle
trois-deux-un-deux-trois-quatre